hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen map vorstellung ja ich hab
gedacht ich mach mal wieder eine map
vorstellung und zwar von der sonic the
hedgehog runway dingsbums von fv disco
das ist eine map in der sie eine welt
von sonic the hedgehog nicht nachgebaut
haben sondern sie so ähnlich gebaut
haben wie sie dort auch sein könnte und
zwar seht ihr das hier schon wenn ich
euch dass ihr zeige das ist ein parcours
ich noch mal kurz auf 1 es ist ein
parcours wo man halt über so ein paar
dingen spa plattform drüber springen
muss überall sind halt so ein paar
sachen angebracht wie zum beispiel
knöpfe oder position wo man drauf
springen muss damit man an ihnen wie
darüber geschleudert wird also oder
bestimmte sachen man muss sich halt den
richtigen weg suchen dass es relativ
schwer den richtigen weg zu finden
und man muss das halt alles so schnell
machen wie es geht das ist alles
ziemlich von zwei relativ groß hier
ich habe es bisher zweimal geübt hat
kein mal den weg bis ins ziel gefunden
also ich wollte ja auch nur die web
zeigen nicht wie es geht ist jetzt
startet am anfang halt hier hier steht
ihr versteht cpm
wir müssen halt am anfang diesen
komischen schalter drücken
start dann sterben wir kurz nein
bestimmt nicht einfach runter wir haben
hier so ein bisschen paar sachen
bekommen und wir müssen halt sofort
loslaufen hier sehen wir eine tripwire
über die ich gelaufen bin
dann startet das hier und wir müssen
jetzt anfangen darüber zu springen
also dass er schon mal richtig das weiß
ich so dann gehts hier
sodann wird man eigentlich da hinten
dann hin geschleudert das hat bei mir
allerdings nicht funktioniert deswegen
ich weiß nicht woran es liegt kontrakt
ab s check point one steht an zum
beispiel im chat
also eigentlich wäre es normal wenn ihr
dann ihn wieder drüber gestolpert wäre
die spitze zum dritten mal
dennoch nicht so allzu der super pro in
minecraft also wenn ich irgendwie geil
des scores daran habt könnt ihr mir die
einfach mal als video antwort senden
eventuell werde ich da ein bisschen was
zu lassen und dann letztlich doch wieder
runter gefallen jedenfalls ganz witzig
dass ihr auch zwei hoch springen könnte
ich diese ganzen sachen das heißt ihr
könnt ihr einfach so wieder hochklettern
da haben wir hier zwei von crafter pest
checkpoint 2 so erweist sich nämlich nie
ich darüber komme nicht darüber gefallen
als ich weiß nicht genau wie das richtig
funktionieren soll mit diesen komischen
teilen da komisches tnt die schneider
nein eigentlich darüber also das ist
normal
nur bei mir funktioniert das ding wenn
ich weiß nicht warum aber naja also da
sollten die eigentlich drauf schleudern
so dann kann man halt die weiteren
blabla hier wusste ich vorher nämlich
nicht wie es weitergeht ach so ab steht
ja ok schaden so hoch okay das erstmal
das geklappt hat so gut wohin jetzt da
unten
3 ok dann laufen wir dahin so weit war
ich jetzt bisher noch nicht mal nicht
vergessen ob ich hab vergessen zu
springen ist was ich laufe einfach mal
so ein bisschen kreuz und quer hierdurch
noch das café falsch ja ich glaube das
ist falsch das wird falsch sein
ich glaub ich laufe den komplett falsche
weg ich weiß gar nicht wo wir sind bei 4
ich weiß wenn ich wie wir hingekommen
sind aber okay wir sind bei 4 so ist auf
nähe her geschafft so was das hier
schnell herunter und hier runter nein da
geht es nicht lang
ich weiß nicht wo es langgeht höher ich
gebe einfach hier lang
scheiße springt auch noch darüber hinaus
nein das kann nicht wahr sein
ich weiß gar nicht wo fünf ist ich mache
das ganze video hier auch nicht um jetzt
hier irgendwie ein heiß zu machen
minecraft expert.de hatte dann wenn es
interessanten hsv gemacht da hinten ist
glaube ich sogar das ende der hat einen
der besten nicht auf den zweitbesten
oder drittbesten bisher insgesamt von
allen von entfernen und welche das nicht
sonst noch alles gemacht haben war auf
jeden fall sehr krass
der dazu geschafft hat aber wie gesagt
ich bin hier um die map vorzustellen um
euch das ganz kurz zu zeigen ja hier ist
dann so dass ende denke ich da läuft man
hier jetzt in dem unter 15 ok 55 jetzt
das ziel aber irgendwie funktioniert die
uhr nicht das verstehe ich nicht
naja jedenfalls bei mir klappt derzeit
nicht ganz so super allerdings habe ich
mir die videos angesehen von fv disco
von minecraft expert.de gehabt dass alle
super also das liegt an ihm wieder an
mir oder ich hab ihnen was falsch
gemacht
ich wollte euch den erhalt nur zeitlich
am ende bekommt ihr dann noch die hall
of fame und die bonus kräfte sich hier
hall of fame bonus gäste und ok das war
jetzt meine abschieds musik ich würde
sagen wenn ihr euch den web download
wollte sie steht in der beschreibung
welche wieder am start
jetzt könnte ich theoretisch hier
nochmal starten dann geht sie wieder ab
gc hat man start vielleicht muss ich
auch nochmal hier draufklicken
naja egal keine ahnung jedenfalls habt
ihr den download in der beschreibung
so jetzt geht's auf grün und jetzt kann
ich loslaufen
na ja er habe dort eine beschreibung uns
selber auszutesten ich würde sagen wenn
euch das video gefallen hat würde ich
mich definitiv für einen daumen hoch
freuen
vielleicht schaffen wir 400 daumen hoch
das wird mir zeigen dass euch das
gefällt dass ich im web reviews mache
oder und ist eine kiste diamanten
gefunden
das wird mir zeigen dass er solche
mapreduce wollt wo ich ein bisschen
lockerer bin und das alles nicht so
können steuern vorstelle oder nie das in
emerald also ich würd mich aber nochmal
freund wir sind zwar nicht mal freunde